- What else you got in here?
I'm full on creeping
through this shop.
I mean, it's not like a lot
of people walk through here.
And we've got access.
So I'm looking at his workbench.
I'm looking up in the rafters.
- Here's a Deets carbide.
- Oh, yeah.
- I'd buy it, sure.
- Oh, there we go.
Can I make you an offer on this?
He's got a Cycle Ray
headlight bucket.
I mean, this will fit pretty
much any older Harley.
They reproduce these,
but the purists
like myself want the real deal.
I mean the reflector is decent.
The bucket doesn't
have much paint on it
but it's got the
reflector, the bezel.
Obviously there's no lens.
I mean, they re-pop
that stuff but--
Well, what are
we talking here?
- For this, $500.
- $500?
- Yeah.
- Serious?
Yeah.
Well, look again.
He's got a lens.
He's go brand new lenses.
Is that the real deal?
Sure looks like it.
So it looks genuine to me.
It's the original lens
in the original box.
How about, with the lens, $700?
We doing it?
You got it.
All right, let's do it.
I was kind of blown
away when he told
me he'd give me $700 for that.
It was like--
I couldn't pass it up.
You got it.
- Take care of it.
I'll put that right on.
Believe me, I've
got a bike for that.
I'll step up to the plate
because I have a bike
that I can put this light on.
I don't want a reproduction.
I want the real deal.
It's what I'm looking at
when I'm going down the road.
I'm looking at the dash.
I'm looking at the handlebars.
And I'm looking at
that headlight, man.
And occasionally I'll
glance at the road.